ah yeah coming down I just rub snot on
my own head hey what's going on
everybody first we feast I'm Sean Evans
and you're watching hot one it's a show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
today I'm joined by Kyle Kinane you can
catch him on the road he has a special
Kyle Kinane loose in Chicago and the
Chicago guy and a man who loves his hot
sauce I feel like this face-to-face
meeting it's long overdue Kyle welcome
to the show thanks for having me I'm
appreciated how are you with hot food I
love it and I get I think there's an
addictive property that gets me uh gets
me really going and before we get it
going the wings they probably look a
little bit strange and that's because
Kyle we're going vegan wings for you
today I'm going vegan right along with
you ready to get going absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's first one is to
Rochester Aceh is no big deal they've
made chicken fingers vegetarian but that
made them look like human fingers so I
want to start by taking it all the way
back to your formative years into Page
County because I spent a lot of Friday
nights in high school taking the track
down I 92 go to shows at the fireside
Bowl not good for the other lighting can
you explain what the fireside Bowl is
what is the fireside it was this rundown
bowling alley and then had a just a
stage a haphazard stage mhm
I think Chicago is a unique in a way
that it wasn't super violent of your of
them kids are dancing in motion once I
did get punched by a guy who was angry
at bumped into him at a Scott show know
you're not supposed to mosh the sky
wasn't it bumped into him but he just
held me and punched me stomach and said
you'll watch this guy lick but I realize
an explanation wasn't going to serve him
at all classic stuff so I'll talk to you
about the supernatural because it seems
to be a big time for the supernatural
and there's somebody who hosts a podcast
on the topic you know that better than
anybody
yeah I've always been fascinated with it
do I believe in it it's a case-by-case
ly I'm very picky about which stories I
choose to believe but I think having the
hope and the imagination that it might
be out there it's just a more pleasant
way to exist and walk it around thinking
you know all the answers and all the
science like it's real cool that ghosts
don't exist God's not real
Wow Europe must be a blast at party
I like this one you see this one - the
good the good Mexican restaurant so for
up to me I would just wax poetic with
you about Chicago until we ran out of
wings but we don't have that kind of
time and I'm supposed to cover more
ground so I concentrated all into this
wing bathroom what's your go-to
Portillo's order oh man jumbo chili dog
with everything and one regular with
everything Gino's East Illuminati's wow
man I don't even [ __ ] with that
deep-dish I love it I love this where'd
it go it's a bucket of cheese it's great
but I'll take hot dogs
the Pete's argument falls flat on me
what's the best bar to get blackout
drunk in after a Cubs game I think just
Wrigleyville in total is its own bar
strung together by small walks between
establishments but I would say the
formerly Gingerman Tavern now the g-man
tavern BAE colada Brendan Kelly my
friend excellent musician and bartender
there on Monday night
that's drunk E so you go on this Al's
Italian beef or you going at the Wiener
circle I'll be honest I only went to
Wiener circle one time and I was like oh
there's a flavor they yell at you and I
wound up having a gun pulled on me well
it was pulled on everybody in the
establishment I'm like this is a bit
much for roughhousing
when I think I was in the middle of like
a gang fight that was not worth the
cheese fries no no I don't remember the
meal at all I just remember firearms
being drawn and a guy with a knife it's
got a cat on a bottle or a wolf
well the Netflix series love opens with
what I would say is an impressively
graphic sexy yeah what is that
experience like what is that process
like basically put your dick and balls
into this gift bag for wine bottles
which is all just look like some sort of
gopher [ __ ] which is a bag with a cinch
on it which they don't work this bug all
right let's hope that nope it fell off
again sorry everyone
fortunately Gillian Jacobs who
same with me as a consummate
professional like as soon as we'd be
done to be a woman like right there with
a robe and after a few cakes like I was
feeling silly and I was kinda like doing
a little bull fighting with her look at
oh you know no that was not professional
probably why I'm not in season two but I
mean it was a weird way to find out that
my mom actually had a Netflix password
well your mom stumbled across that
organically and yeah yeah call your
phone yeah those way more awkward than
the actual scene so that's a little
sweet mm-hmm all right so the next part
of the show is called explain that
Graham we do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram we pull interesting pictures
that need more contact oh boy so I've
pulled a handful of Kyle Kinane IG pics
I'll just show them to you and you give
me the bigger story that's - yeah all
right let's top please
looks like you're what getting a ticket
at Wrigley Field only a little bit left
yeah that is me getting a ticket in
front of a Cubs game last - was so
excited with two years ago I was having
beer and then the gated doors were just
open after the game and Chicago's finest
stop me does that mean the Duke we
caught a cop in a rare moment where he's
not shooting somebody the heartwarming
picture right yeah look at him not just
shooting an unarmed team so believe it
or not this is actually our second Froot
Loops bath on explain that Graham
shoutout to Bobby Lee he won here Ruth
loops bath - can you talk to me about
what's going on here this is my friends
were doing a sketch that never aired and
like again I think like I get called to
be the go-to guy with some partial
nudity and no body shame shout out to
that cause nobody should be body shamed
look at that you'd be proud I was having
a couple of little Harry B cups and
god-awful tattoos I think you look great
Kyle thank you this is an interesting
picture it's new with a bottle of
Cholula and it took on a life of its own
after you posted it and I have to think
that kind of took you by
surprise you know people just desperate
for things to go viral
the guys Cholula is eating it was
shirtless ly eating some food like oh
this would be funny and it failed one of
these we take everybody else's [ __ ]
instagrams where they call them
aggregators yeah great people great
people necessary to the world one of
these aggregator sites got a hold of it
and so now still every week there's
still somebody just look like LMFAO this
is totally me trying to use it my god
now that we're in the back nine I think
it's important that we acknowledge that
we're eating vegan wings today for Kyle
Kinane and that might surprise some
uncle barbecue fans is that a product of
moving to LA is that a product of
turning 40 I was already kind of toying
with vegetarianism when I was getting
the point where I realized it was more
like how nonchalantly I would eat meat
be dread take the five freeway from LA
to San Francisco you'll go by a very
large cattle ranch I just see that the
hills are black with cows [ __ ] and they
smell and they're all crammed in and
then I would just like get to San
Francisco and go to Burger King and not
think any big twice about that so it got
to me a little bit so yeah I'm trying
I'm not committed to it I don't have any
righteous beliefs for me personally it
was the way I wanted to go with my life
also the gout thing avoid too much meat
I can't walk and it sucks Kyle I feel a
little bit I'll oh let's not act like I
didn't put my time in I mean this is the
part we're in a YouTube comments that we
can call me a [ __ ] and that's time
because that's what you're supposed to
do when you comment on YouTube videos
this is Dombey apocalypse and how I'd
say this you're a hot dog I expected you
to be fine
here's your first real test where we're
going to get into zombie apocalypse got
it right in there mm-hmm all right the
last season we had t-pain on and he has
some crazy food series and food hotcakes
but you make him look like nothing
you've got the hottest now chill down
yeah everybody got t-pain
so what we want to do with you is what
we did with him which is bring out some
of his more controversial food tweets
represent them to them and then maybe
you can explain what set you off
way more than 140 characters will allow
okay okay all right so this first one is
about salsa and I think it's a brilliant
point we've been eating salsa for years
and nobody's thought to make the jar
wider instead of taller so you can get
the chips in there easier some talking
about that I'm basically like an ethical
pharmaceutical company I could be making
a million dollars off these ideas if I
were just quiet about it and implemented
them but instead let's put it out in the
world
for free salsa companies come on a big
old tub
I've got like a little tiny pool so the
chip to go from one side to the other
boom you're getting every last bite out
of there it's just common sense all
right next one Miracle Whip label says
it's salad dressing if I saw someone put
Miracle Whip on a salad I'd call the
cops
I love Miracle Whip too which is a
controversial opinion a lot of people
have problems Manning and then people
that are with mayonnaise have a problem
with Miracle Whip like but just like you
what do you sleep with the lights on
come on
it's desti mayonnaise and in no way at
all should have come near a salad pile
not trying to blow too much smoke up
your ass but I think this is one of your
better observation Anthony Bourdain got
all his tattoos done with an eight
months of each other like a new suicide
girl I already heard Elvis truly as I
was a funny joke and then like I got a
couple Bourdain heads out there like
he's been getting them on his travels
through the past seven years so I'm
never watching his show and he
got like one on his arm and now I saw
him not like whole thing's covered in
them like all right we get it
he did arrow it I could see how this
could harm a child
yeah I guess the others could rebel
adults sweating from the face over here
yeah the bombs brutal all right do I
keep eating yeah like it's not real
funny
[Music]
yeah Sheldon eight yeah good too it's
rolled out they do shoot two sets
tonight Chuck bullet wet diarrhea
wearing my pity shirt but I was
wondering why my career wasn't was
plateauing Kyle he's in the bathroom
still um put somebody else on my first
first sip of milk I'm going to take on
this one go for it let the record show
great run Kyle so as I see end up you
and Hal comes in the brain some of the
greatest barfly stories out there I'm
not going to make you tell any of them
on the bomb hot sauce for the YouTube
audience out there you can go down that
rabbit hole all day long but if somebody
with such a deep fondness for dive bars
I do wonder what separates a good one
from a bad one I like [ __ ] not not
prefabricated shuttles just something
where like the wonderful bar in LA
called the drawing room or if you go
during the day I've been going there for
years and finally during the day the
door opened up and I look down I was
like wait a minute there's carpet in
here and it's just because it would
shine and carpet shouldn't shine but
you've been so much crap and still
dumped into it like I know it's not a
good thing like that's not a great
review of a barb like that is oh but
that's the barb it's like it's a beat
you came here to have drinks we want you
to have drinks you want to sing with the
songs too loud and play plastic darts
get a little loose in the mouth yell
about how you almost got shot at a
hotdog place in Chicago this is the
place to do it
this is me pretty hot a gas yeah you
think what you think of it it's hot but
you also think but now you're you're
going bozo buckets yep difficulty yep
from them does anybody else made both of
buckets computers no you're the first
one girl breaking ground here good
sometimes I think I'm a hack and then
once in a while you [ __ ] tumble on
with Jim I'm hot on the lips so we've
touched on it a little bit but I want to
talk to you about Twitter for a second
because you once wrote as a comedian I
feel obligated to show up on social
media like it's my [ __ ] shift at
Arby's I hate this [ __ ] which is
something I think a lot of people can
relate to me haven't come at it later
like alright I guess I'm shooting myself
in the foot if I don't participate in
but so much of it just so masturbatory
like comedians on instagram are [ __ ]
worthless and then the arguing and the
political just badgering and just
impotent whining about stuff like [ __ ]
this whole thing that I have to be a
part of so anyway it's at Kyle Kinane on
Twitter and Instagram do you ever really
seriously think about deleting at all oh
I would take Twitter off my phone
everyone's when I realize I started
arguing with controls like what happened
to shame what happened to the point
clear if somebody's its own so thinks
you were an [ __ ] as now you like oh
what did I say I don't think I'm an
[ __ ] I don't want to be an [ __ ]
that's how I was brought up you don't
want to be an [ __ ] and everybody's
like yeah I'm an [ __ ] deal with it no
I shouldn't have to deal with it you're
part of society be a decent person
otherwise [ __ ] walk into traffic Oh
hot sauce got me angry
I like it's called Megadeth sauce but
who made it Blair
get ready for it I'm always ready for it
this is Blair's Megadeth sauce of liquid
rage it's tradition around here to put a
little dab on the last one you don't
have to if you don't want to Kyle
because you oh you want me to put it on
yeah well that's probably good this has
been kind of a runny tap lately had some
I mean the jokes right there but the
people at home with the running tab joke
in it that I mean I'm a professional
level I've already made a lot of time
uShip here's to the Greater Atlanta area
get on the tongue probably a dumb move
no it's common in which it's all
encompassing Lee warm mm-hmm
but not unpleasant Yura Blair's that
make it that soft man I respect the hell
let me get it around in there I'm not
trying to be a tough guy or anything but
I had a hard time with the mad dog maybe
I got like a finger not a pet frog go
ahead and go for it but I would suggest
your your Kyle you shouldn't shy away
from the fact that you are a little bit
of a hot sauce here oh yeah totally
stupid yeah you shouldn't have to
apologize for that either when we go to
apologize for everything else
none of this
sweating I dig it
you're into it I thought that actually
it's very very hot but I would put it I
would I would put it over here on Kyle
respect I would put it there the bomb a
little bit tougher for you Yahoo now I
want now it's in the windpipe it's a
tough place for it to be every time talk
of Benguet and the real
what's wrong but feel good like I feel
good just feel alive I feel alive I love
it label fulfilled its promises as we've
touched down already
your cult hero you're a comedian's
comedian but some people might not know
that you're that voice I'm Comedy
Central I think now there's a lot of
light bulbs going off with our fans who
are like oh now oh oh I've been
wondering where that voice is coming
from so I want to challenge you on
Blairs Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
now that you know a little bit about the
show to give us a promo that hot ones
has always dreamed of well a Trickett
like this is how I got my professional
voice was three years of abuse lots of
city miles throw some I throw some
generic brand cigarettes and cheap beer
on top of it and this is where you get
there oh yeah number one hyper close
right there I love that what is he would
have you guys didn't have numbers
all right confused everybody where Mike
amber one I don't know I'll split the
difference that's a terrible shot for
both of you guys this is why I only do
voiceover not in person stuff yes yeah
Wednesday's 8:00 p.m. check out hot ones
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wing Wow
the way that had my ear that was so
perfect well you made it through you
given a plug it was amazing and I think
that it's only fair that we return the
favor this camera that camera that
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
I don't have much they asked me two days
ago I had the evening free to come eat
hot sauce for free I respect how much is
going on my life no offense show I wish
my calendar was more full
I also jumped at the chance because I do
I get a meal I got a I got comedy
special out there online somewhere I
usually go with a Google search because
I don't know where they are welcome Kyle
Kinane in Google and if there's a way
that you can give me money go for it I
think it's a decent product
I mean I'll back it up and it's just
like a big guy like like just like sales
looks like oh no ha outtakes everybody
all right
what fellow light yeah that's a quite
like hey what's going on hot ones fans
if you like the video maybe meet us
halfway throw us a subscribe if you
didn't like the video don't subscribe I
don't want you I don't want you in the
tent but if you like the video subscribe
thank you very much I appreciate you I
love you more than a friend